okay so let's start with White's most
frequent Choice namely e captures D5 and
after this my recommendation is
straightforward you continue with E4
okay white has two choices
the main line start with Queen to E2
however if you play this line below 2000
many white players will outright move
the knights somewhere and I think this
is where the big mistake starts as black
and sees the initiative just within the
opening stage
[Music]
not so surprising there are some high
profile tricks and traps exist here as
well for example by far the most popular
choice is
Knight to D4
and as soon as that night moves Black's
move is very obvious yup you capture on
D5 attacking that Knight
to B3 and now the key move you have to
remember is Queen to E5
this move stops any D or F Pawn movement
because then we can simply take it and
give white a discover check
so obvious enough white has to find the
other root and if you just keep looking
at the top moves here for example Knight
to C3
we play Knight to C6
trying to take out of a queen side
pieces first
and after Bishop to E2
the star move Bishop to D6
with stops what to Castle and trust me
most of the white players get frustrated
here
because they are not used to this kind
of initiative from the Black
so they literally lash out with either
D3 or D4
in both the case we are going to take
the spawn
and as you can see here
Queen captures D3 happened in roughly
150 games which I'm afraid leads to a
completely losing position
yup here our first trick occurs
black can play this very accurate move
night to before which more or less
finished the game just within the
opening stage
why well the obvious answer is we are
tracking two locations and after Queen
to D1
no price for guessing splack's obvious
response yup Bishop to fi and that poor
C2 Pawn can no longer defend it
well many games here continue with
Knight to D4 which looks like defending
the pawn as well as attacking the bishop
but it turns out as a great time
disaster as black has this tactical
resource
Queen captures D4
sacrificing a queen but winning the
piece as if white takeover Queen then
after Knight capture C2 at the end of
the sequence we are coming out as a
complete piece up
so as you can see if Knight moves
anywhere then after Queen captures D5
black get a very good game
so Queen to E2 what else
now what is spinning of a pawn and also
pressurizing it and accordingly we need
to protect it with night to F6
well we are into one of the most
important Crossroad of this line where
what has two major Alternatives number
one Knight to C3 and number two main
line
T3
let's look at first Knight to C3 which
looks very obvious
attacking the pawn with multiple times
and rather than defending this pawn and
going into the defensive move I
recommend this very attacking approach
you start with Bishop to E7
so now we are threatening the Knight so
white response is forced he has to take
on e4
and after this you simply Castle on the
king side
so you can see by sacrificing one Pawn
now we are streaming ahead in terms of
Peace development and our most important
feature is
as the wide major PCS are situating on
the e-file our Rook EA can create
disaster forward in many different
variations
now watch out this as you are about to
witness one of the most high profile
trap in this line where if white
continue with D3 which in fact happens
in roughly 8 000 games
see how crafty this trap is as black and
white both can continue with
top choices as per the database and yet
white fall for it
isn't that amazing
just watch out the top moves in the
database
first Knight captures D5
Bishop to D2 trying to Castle
we play Rook to E8 allowing white to
Castle but after f i white is losing the
piece
nope he cannot move the Knight well
that's the thing here you may wonder why
so let's start with the most frequent
Choice Knight to C3
big blunder because after Knight capture
C3
no matter however white recapture us he
is going to lose his Queen
if B capture C3 then this is the easiest
one you give this check and nap the
White Queen
so that's not good if Bishop captures C3
then this time around we have Bishop to
G5 check
and after the following transaction
Knight captures G5 Rook captures E2
Bishop captures E2 and the move Queen
captures G5
if you carefully count the material
white has clearly lost his Queen for The
Rook
probably this one is my favorite trap
amongst all elephant Gambit tricky
territory
well some of you may say well white
don't need to play Knight to C3 from
here he can also play Knight to G3 right
well yep he can this time around white
is not going to lose his Queen but he is
definitely losing a piece after Bishop
to F6
and funny enough this queen doesn't have
any Square to go so white has to block
it
and after that yup F4 and plaque is
really enjoying this Gambit
well some of the greedy white player
will continue with C4 defending his
deepawn but this sort of things does not
work against our Gambit because again we
have a nasty forcing trap here starting
with Knight takes E4 Queen takes E4 and
now obvious move Rook to E8
well white has to do something or his
Queen is a complete corner so Bishop to
E2 blocking the E far what else and
after our Bishop to F6
Queen to D3 is the obvious choice
well black can play Queen to E7 and stop
white to Castle
but I found even the stronger
continuation starting with
C6
white can't take it as his Queen is
hanging
so most of the games continue here with
Castle
but after that we can simply take on D5
and after C captures D5
the stunner B6
what a move
and guess what black has obvious threat
namely Bishop to A6 and nabbing this
piece
and funny enough even though I can see
it's coming
amazingly he cannot stop it
the best he can do over here is D6
and after our Bishop to E6 the big idea
is
Queen to defy
but I found a amazing Queen trap line in
this video
by going through the following sequence
Bishop takes E2 Queen captures eight
Bishop takes F1
King takes F1 and now Queen captures D6
so as you can see we have completely
taken all the squares from the white
camp
and our Queen is literally looking at
this juicy D3 Square
so accordingly most of the games
continue here with D4 preventing Our
Queen intrusion but that leads to their
Queen trap after Black's wonderful reply
Queen to D7
so our planning is very simple we want
to play Knight to C6 and get the White
Queen
and no matter whatever white plays he
cannot prevent it
for example difa is one of the accurate
choice but blackened played equally
clever move Rook to see it taking the
control of C6
and after Bishop to F4 and the Moon
Knight to E6
finally we have trapped down the white
sweetie
okay so that's why by far
the most popular choice is Knight
captures F6 and after Bishop takes F6
as you can see I have highlighted by the
arrows white has three major choices
well to be honest frequently whenever I
reach this position most of my opponents
continue with this blunder move namely
D3 which in fact as per the database
played in more than 1500 times
and again this leads to a trappy
territory where blacks just finished the
white in the opening stage
let's see it
first you give this check
allowing white what he wants to do
Bishop to E3 but at the end when we take
on B2
white position become a complete Mass
for example Rook to be even attacking
the bishop
we give this check
and after Knight to D2 we can simply
take on D5
so not only black has regained all of
his material but now is threatening the
E2 Pawn
and accordingly white has continued with
Rook to B3 counter-attacking the black
Bishop
and after of a queen to A5
doesn't matter how River white plays
let's say A3 and G3 are one of the most
popular choices but against all of this
black get the winning combo
so let's see what is the big idea
after any of this moves let's say A3
we will start with Knight to C6 and as
you can see the threat is very obvious
not to D4 and nabbing the exchange
if you think white can defend this
position just pause the video and find
out
you will be amazed how difficult this
position is for the white cap
for example just one of my recent game
my opponent continued with Queen to D1
so he clearly want to play Bishop to E2
and get out of this Mass
but against this I deliver my home
preparation with this fantastic move
boom
clearly the queen cannot Escape
otherwise the Knight on D2 hangs and in
the game he played Bishop to E2 which
actually by force leads to the position
black wants after Bishop takes Queen
takes and the move
yep Knight to D4 and literally white can
back his back and go home
well the second move I want to consider
is Queen to C4
which can be played by a greedy player
so his idea is he wants to play Bishop
to E2 and castle
but it is not going to work out as after
a simple Rook check
Bishop to E2 and now this amazing move
sets up a cunning trap namely
be fine
if white is full enough to take this
Pawn then after Bishop to A6
we are winning the piece at just 10th
move of the game
so that is right out of the equation
and afterwards obvious choice Queen to
D3
we continue of a tricky Journey with C5
so our goal is to play C4 and dislodge
the White Queen
so once again white response is force he
has to take this Pawn
but after the following transaction
Queen captures D3 Pawn captures D3 and
the Moon Knight to C6
if you carefully count the material here
white is two Pawn ah
but amazingly enough
if you put this position in any chess
engine it will tell you that white is
almost two point down
isn't that amazing
and the conclusion is obvious enough
because white king is permanently caught
in the center and as I have highlighted
over here black has some nasty plants
which will completely dismant the whole
wide position
last but not least probably the most
important move here is default which is
in fact recommended by a Grandmaster in
a current accessible course
so let me show you what's White's idea
after this I certainly recommend you
play Queen captures D5
attacking the pawn and when white plays
Bishop to E3 you can continue with
Bishop to G4
in the course author suggest that white
should play H3 and he only considered
the move Bishop to F5 after that when
white plays C3 he coming out as a clear
Pawn advantage
but what I suggest here is you first
take this Knight and after Queen takes
you play this crafty queen move Queen to
if I which definitely catch unprepared
wide opponent of God
it has not been analyzed in any course
so you have every chance to get a good
game out of this
first thing very obvious white cannot
play Bishop to D2 as after Queen to B6
we are attacking multiple locations
so that's right out of the equation
C3 has been forced here
and now we play this nice move Knight to
C6
so our goal is very obvious as the C3
point is spin we want to play Bishop
captures D4 and get our material back
now if you check this position in
database the top choices are Bishop to
D3 and castle
which I don't think so give any
advantage to White
let's see why so the first move I want
to consider is a bad move yet frequently
played namely Bishop to D2
after this we continue with Rook check
and after Bishop to E2
we simply put our Queen on the B6 Square
the big point is it doesn't matter how
River White Castle
let's say queen side Castle defending on
B2 but missing the important tactic
namely Bishop capacity for
so if y doesn't capture then this
position is at least equal for black
and if why take it
then after Knight captures D4
black will regain his peace back with an
extra Pawn advantage
so that's why Bishop to D2 is a very bad
move in this position
let's see top choices of database number
one Bishop to D3
not impressed simple tactic Bishop
captures D4
and after a sample line
Castle Bishop takes Queen takes
Rook to E8
Queen to G3 and after Rook a to d8
not only black has gained his material
but his Rook has been centralized and in
terms of practical play if anyone is
slightly better that is obviously black
okay let's check out what happens if
White Castle on the queen side
well this is very easy you get your Pawn
back with Queen captures A2 and after
White's Bishop to D3
it is fair to say that game Remain the
double edge
for example I can show you a recent game
where black continued with Knight to E7
and meeting White's aggression of G4
with Knight to defy
okay jifa is not possible due to Knight
captures E3 so in the game white plays
Queen to F5
and his idea is that after the moon G6
he wants to exchange the queen with
Bishop to B1
and at first sight this looks attractive
except one problem that black has a
nasty trick in this position namely
Knight capture C3 what a move
now obviously white can't take this
Knight as after Queen chat White Queen
hangs on a fire so in the game White
Shoes Bishop takes A2 but after Knight
takes King to B1
Pawn takes F5 King takes Knight
F captures G4 and add captures G4 the
dust is clear and at the end black
emerged with a clear Pawn advantage
so that's all you need to know if your
opponent plays Knight to C3 remember
this golden plan you play Bishop to E7
sacrificing the E4 Pawn so that after we
Castle we can exploit the major pieces
of white on the E file by playing Rook
to E8 and as I have shown in this video
even though white has multiple options
he has to really watch out not only some
high profile tricks but some of the
great nuances as I have suggested in
this video
which at the end gives black a
completely entertaining